that's what should be on the website
okay that's what I should feel and that
gets you clients I'm just sent you
directly directly uh my page that I just
built in about three days to get your
critique this is you that was me and I
think uh 2016 more or less yeah wow dude
what a journey congratulations knowing
your audience really matters so Tanya
just gave a whole bunch of great tips
for how to Target the female consumer
Chris becomes the face of Fitness for
America you're the new whoever what
you're about to watch is a special
private training session for people who
bought a copy of my book built to serve
enjoy
Chris had a hands up before we even got
here so what's on your mind man uh well
first I read your momentum book cover to
cover in probably three days amazing
book I'm glad Nina is doing okay I've
done the whole two percent thing and the
5.95 uh and I'm just sent you directly
directly uh my page that I just built in
about three days to get your critique
and that's pretty much it that was it
desire for iron.com yes sir all right
let's check out desire you guys can go
I'll share my screen make it easy for
everybody tell us about it and and how
can I help what's your question so I'm
kind of doing the whole like you know
showing the from Pain to
pleasure if you will okay this is you
that was me and I think uh 2016 more or
less yeah wow dude what a journey
congratulations thank you thank you and
so the free ebook is the first funnel
okay that's the most embarrassing
picture ever and then that's you know
going on and on and on to better bigger
and better things there's some
testimonials
all that good stuff and I'm just
okay that's cool so what are we trying
to sell Chris personal training packages
so if you go just under the what are we
about there's the personal training
packages okay there's the workout
there's just the nutrition or of course
the best value being both together it's
a telephone app so whether you live in
Brunswick Ohio because that's like the
number one hot spot in America or you
live in Venezuela you can sign up it's
right on your phone what what's the
number one hot spot in America uh
Brunswick Ohio okay just a little south
of Cleveland the vacation hot spot of
the world right okay
uh so yeah it's right there you know
it's right on your phone
um it's workouts of course you got
access to me specifically if you got
questions you know it's all
everything's on the phone these days you
know what I mean so it's just handy
dandy phone uh reach out to you set up
your macronutrients your calories all
that good stuff whether you want to be
the person in a speedo in a spray tan or
you just want to get in really really
good shape
that's what I'm about you know not
everybody wants to compete but at the
end of the day
there's a man by the name of a doctor Dr
Ted Naaman he said it perfectly we are
all bodybuilders and what that means is
you're a reflection of your diet and
exercise whether that's good or bad
that's what you are just by definition
so it's like even though not everybody
wants to compete everybody probably
wants to at least be in some modicum of
health and that's where I come in okay
cool I love it man and congrats and and
you know getting the first version of a
page up is hard and it
sometimes hard to look at and critique
you know after all this time and effort
put in so congratulations couple of
first thoughts when you are for
everybody you're kind of for nobody like
it's really hard to start selling your
services when it's very broad okay who
do you work best with you know you said
I can go bodybuilder all the way down to
Average Joe like who do you love working
with the most whether it's you know age
demographics mindset like who Do You
Love hitting the most okay my dream
customer would be someone like myself
someone who is
um doesn't want to use steroids under
that stuff I ain't about that but
somebody who's just probably in their
late 30s early 40s I'm I'll be 48 next a
couple weeks so probably somebody in
their 40s male or female that is just
tired of being overweight and recognizes
that it's going to take hard work
there's no such thing as a shortcut it's
hard work and you're willing to put in
the work you're you're just you're done
with
the whole sad dieting and the whole like
sad workouts like I'm not gonna name any
workouts because they all work but it's
whether or not you're going to do it's a
different story you know first off I'm
jealous I don't know 48 you have so much
hair so that that's a whole other thing
that you can
I'm 42 dude you're looking great at 48.
thank you
next is okay if you're talking about
just being out of shape and getting in
shape most people who are in that
position aren't taking steroids at all
okay right so right if you're going
steroids now you're thinking like
bodybuilding Elite or I just really want
to get insanely buff
right I think everybody can relate to
hey I want to lose some weight sure but
most of those people are not thinking I
need steroids to do it right okay so but
that's fine like that could be your
audience like you're you want the people
who really want to get
big even this is like this is this is
not the ambition for most people okay to
compete in spray time most people
actually think this is weird Okay sure
right like most guys in America would
see this guy and say that's crazy I'm
never wearing a speedo or thong or
whatever and like spraying my this is
insane this is crazy this is stupid
right okay sure but it doesn't mean you
necessarily have to get people ready for
competition although that could that's
definitely a model you could follow sure
but the people who look at this and say
yeah man that's what I want to be
but very different than the average Joe
you know kind of on the street who's
trying to figure out how to lose 15
pounds sure even in the naming right so
like if I looked at desire for iron
Fitness
it feels like a much more masculine
brand I don't know how many women are
out there like really tie into pumping
iron that feels more masculine but then
the colors are are a lot more
feminine and soft you've got like the
bright yellows and the like the pinks
and
um you know the Light blues so like who
are we trying to Target
if you want to Target like
women for example right you could start
here but then and the colors all fit but
it maybe not like wanting to be this guy
sure or unless it's the women who want
to be bodybuilders and like you're gonna
help them or just get to that kind of
state so I would start with who do you
want to actually serve okay and it's
okay if you want if you want to be the
the guy maybe and I'm just don't don't
let me put words in your mouth it's
actually who you are you know the guy
who takes people who want to I don't
know what the term would be maybe not go
pro or compete but like even just
below that right right where they might
even consider like an amateur performer
or an amateur where like they actually
look at this and say yeah I want I want
to spray tan myself and I want to like
that could be really cool maybe I'm not
gonna go be Mr Olympia but if I could do
something right and you're the guy like
you could be the guy to teach me how to
like who's who's teaching that sure and
probably not many people okay but but
who's teaching how can you lose weight
and start eating better like everybody
right
so that would be the difference like if
we can it's not that you can't win doing
the the everybody it just takes an
incredibly long time to build up the
brand to be that guy okay
because there's so many people who are
out there doing it who even if you have
a better system they have a bigger brand
right now and it's just right now right
like you could get there but this is
that's a 10-year journey to be like the
face of Fitness for America is a
decade-long journey right right where
most people go broke along the way
because they can't sell their thing
because they don't have to pick in that
brand so I would be looking at
what's a more Niche thing for you that
instead of 130 a month as your max
package is a thousand a month
sure okay and you're training them to
get a much more specific skill
okay so you're not necessary you're not
necessarily the guy for everybody it
doesn't mean we have to like push people
away and like hey if you don't want to
be a bodybuilder you suck like we're not
we're not uh right right but but people
self-select in sure okay so I call me
maybe even like have like a silver
package a gold package on like a
platinum package you know what I'm
saying kind of something like that like
maybe the Platinum is for the guy that
wants to be a competitor
the gold is the one who wants to make
his ex-wife jealous and the silver is
the guy who's just trying to get started
that's amazing
um but like that kind of language is now
we're talking now we're honestly now
we're talking like now we're talking
about who you want to reach right okay
yeah yeah I want to make my actual life
be jealous you know
um
but I would still focus on uh
what is what kind of value do you have
to give somebody is going to pay you a
thousand dollars a month
like let's start getting you paid let's
give you a six-figure business sure so
then you can rely on and build on start
building your brand on to then be able
to invest back into these
be the guy for America program what's
different maybe it's not even app
anymore you know like what's the thing
if you're selling a thousand dollars a
month what do you need to do what's the
problems that those people are facing if
somebody wants
you know to be
this guy or even this guy you know like
competing or maybe potentially competing
in some local small show or whatever
right what does he struggle with
that is different than than this guy
say the um that guy with the distended
belly you know they're that guy's
dealing with a lot of self-esteem issues
a lot of health problems and the like
but the guy who's going from that to the
uh dude two pictures down
that's the guy who's dealing with
trying to stay away from those eating
problems that got him to that point to
begin with and sometimes needs to
No One's Gonna call me at two o'clock in
the morning because they want to drink a
fifth of whiskey and eat a pizza but you
know somebody who wants to like maybe an
accountability on a weekly if not
practically a couple days a week basis
you know like okay how are we feeling
how are we doing what's going on you
know sending messages maybe even you
know setting up a zoom call maybe weekly
for that guy the person on the silver
package negative I you know I actually
have to see my wife once in a while and
then maybe the gold guy bi-weekly I
would do the uh the zoom meetings or
something like that
yeah so
everybody needs accountability you know
at every level but the thing is that
somebody like
um
somebody who wants to be like this
they'll listen to you it's like it needs
to be accountability from the right
person okay accountability from somebody
who like you can actually push them in a
loving way forward and actually hold
their feet to the fire like if
somebody's
if somebody's posting a video a week I
was just on a zoom call right before
this with a guy who's posting three
videos a week and he didn't post on
Labor Day
like why didn't you post Labor Day
like you could have had it you could
have had it posted and like how do we
get the four videos a week and then
seven videos a week because he's in
aggressive like growth he wants to be
this guy the equivalent but on YouTube
right okay and he's got 300 000
followers
and you it's like okay dude but this is
the time like you need to be posting on
Labor Day you need to figure out we need
to hire a team we need to get that
person we talked about it two months ago
you have to get that person like so it's
a hard push right most people in most
people's eyes he's already crushing it
he's got 300 000 Subs he's making a lot
of money he's growing like it's a great
life but he'll listen to me because I'm
ahead of him right if if random person
said hey you should be posting more it's
like what are you talking about what are
you posting nothing right so you've done
this so you have the credibility to push
and to give the feedback and so the
accountability means something because
they want to be like you right right
okay right so I would honestly look at
probably just two packages
okay start I would I would like the the
app is not the thing
okay I would ditch the app
all of this all of this is geared
towards like entry-level people it's
just all towards this person but that's
not who we actually want to serve okay I
would have one package that is is one on
one with you okay that's a thousand
dollars a month and whatever that is if
it's like a weekly call
but they get however long what do they
actually need to solve the problem
because they know a little bit about
nutrition already if they're already you
know they want to be this guy they know
don't eat cheeseburgers and you know
like they know a lot of but they need
the nobody everybody thinks they're
crazy their whole family thinks they're
great you want to do what you want to
stand in a bikini and spray tan yourself
are you crazy like nobody supports them
right and you're the guy right like
Arnold had the picture of what's his
name and his in his in his room oh Steve
Reeves yeah no Steve Reeves
yeah not Christopher's Steve Reeves and
then uh or someone else um Reds Park reg
Park Arnold is in the Army in Austria
working out doing poses everybody thinks
he's gay right and like making fun of
him and he's got these pictures of reg
park on the wall who was like Mr Olympia
or whatever like I'm maybe getting some
of the details wrong but like that was
the thing that it that kept him going
where everybody thought he was crazy
where he like sneaks out of the Austrian
camp at night to take a train to go
enter some bodybuilding competition and
wins and comes back and like this starts
his journey so you become that guy for
them but actually somebody that they
could talk to and connect with okay so
what does that person need
that it's a thousand dollars a month
that you're still seeing your wife and
stuff but this is your business now
where you're you're helping people right
and then the package down would be a
group version of it
where if they don't want the one-on-one
with you they're meeting one so we kind
of like what we're doing here you know
this is free or you know spent two bucks
and bought the ebook cool you know
minimum entry to come here but I just I
love this right sure but this this isn't
my business this becomes your business
here
I see okay it's group but still the same
kind of guys
who want to do that and you're giving
them community
they just may not have the budget to be
able to pay a thousand dollars a month
to you
so it's a group group program for them
and then and then the one-on-one with
you and then you design it so that
you're making enough money to support
your lifestyle your business hire team
Etc
um and then this page needs to speak to
younger you not not this version like
massively overweight it's cool that you
came from this so I know but really it's
like how do I get to be this guy and
maybe this guy and what do I need to see
so what what what would you need to see
like would you sign up now like seeing
this is pretty cool right but I may not
be starting from here like this guy
doesn't want to be this guy right
right so help me be help me become this
guy
and those two packages and so then like
the then the naming could work you like
iron cool yeah desire for iron that now
makes more sense to be this guy
um
so maybe get rid of the chubby guy and
the banner right there and just have
like me you know doing my thing or
yeah I would make all this smaller so it
doesn't take up the whole page here
because this is all kind of okay okay
but just try to tap back into like how
long ago was this Chris here
2019. okay so like try to tap back into
Chris in 2019. okay what would he want
to see on a website what would you want
to do what would you want to do like
just before going on here I don't know
how nervous you were or you know
just before doing your first competition
where you're going to be wearing a
speedo and have like a tiny little
number attached to it yeah all of the
fears and insecurities and like am I
crazy and what the heck am I doing and
you know is this nuts
but if you if this Chris or like the
Chris a year before this had 2022 Chris
as a coach and a mentor and a guide
right right and saw that website what
would make you want to sign up okay
tapping back into 2019 Chris and then
having the whole thing speak to them
okay 2019 Chris doesn't want a workout
app
sure okay sure okay and this and then
this becomes the bigger long-term
picture like Chris becomes the face of
Fitness for America you're the new
whoever
um
new bill self or what other guy's name
is yeah okay yeah I'll pick it up cool
man all right I just wanted to share a
couple things with uh with uh Chris uh
because I'm a consumer of those apps so
I'm just gonna put myself in the in this
on the hot seat here like
um something that is really attractive
for girls is when you promote a specific
type of exercises like for targeting
specific parts of the body like that's
how I got into one of those because I
was I wanted to you know I wanted to to
exercise more in this or that part so
that's one thing that is really
attractive for for for girls
um and other friends that you know also
consume that and um also uh the time you
know how how knowing how fast you will
get some result like um the app that I
got it's uh I have it in my phone I do
it like every morning of my life I take
it you know regardless of where I am
it's on my my phone I just play it and I
do it and it's 20 minutes it's 20
minutes and I feel that you know it has
worked well so that's something else
that I think that day and and also what
I've noticed in your website is that
there are no
pictures of girls so if I see if I check
it like very fast I would never have
thought that is for ladies like I yeah
my immediate thought was this is for
bodybuilders or something like that okay
it's it that that's uh something and
also
um maybe videos of you being Charming
because that's how I actually went to
the pages
okay the guy was Charming
and who has your time sorry that I'm
showing my superficial side which is
great and this is great this is why like
having knowing your audience really
matters so Tanya just gave a whole bunch
of great tips for how to Target the
female consumer sure if you're targeting
the people who want to potentially
compete
they likely don't care how Charming you
are they want you to kick their ass
right right so it totally changes how
you show up so I love the idea of having
a video of you on the page and you
talking about what you're gonna do
the message to America would be charming
and crisp and smiling and you can do
this Chris is going to take me from you
know where I'm at to compete I don't
want the the Charming guy I want the guy
who's going to Bulldog me into doing it
like call me out tell me where I suck
and like hold me accountable right so
without uh inflating my ego even more
when you're saying being Charming what
do you mean like just like showing
videos of like workouts or just talking
and presenting myself or what do you
mean uh he actually had like a live
scenes of life coaching he talking with
a lady and discussing her concerns okay
you know how do you feel about this
about that and her journey she was
sharing her journey uh how she became
fit so yeah and uh his General like what
I've seen because he he's big like he
has lots of followers and he has an
Instagram page he has a Facebook page
and everything and uh in the in the ads
what the way he shows is like nice like
you are like you know nice talking and
saying you know
um this that exercise will help you to
get this and that you know so it's
nothing like he's nothing too crazy I
would say just so like but he talks to
in the in his ads and in his videos he
talks to like he he talks and explain
what he's offering with that and uh the
only thing I've all always thought about
is that he misses during the trainings
he misses maybe a little bit of
inspirational part like yo only you know
counts the time and direct you through
the exercises but he never goes to why
you should continue engaged like tap
into your reason why you are doing it
that's the only thing I would say he
misses but yeah Chris if I just quickly
pop back on your website you only have
one picture and it's of this guy Nick
right right again who's our target
market like to Tanya's point if you want
somebody Charming go look up Matthew
Hussey sure sure Matthew hacion if you
know him he's a dating coach
for women on how to get men
sure
he's got the smile he's got the hair
he's got the vibe you know he's very
Charming he's very kind he's very you
know he's not like go look up his
interviews if you wanted to go after
that market cool looking at him you know
this looks great you know like how many
seniors would love to go from this to
this and be like Nick probably a lot of
people sure uh but is this like is women
our Market is the everyday women our
Market is is seniors like Nick our
Market or is it we want to we want to
Target like 2019 Nick and turn him into
a beast like I said my dream customer
would be somebody that either wants to
kill it um the customers I have now I
have I have Nick
um I have another person uh full
disclosures my mom and she's killing it
too she's in that the e-book and she
looks great so I can put pictures of her
up she's uh married to Nick so Nick's my
stepfather uh and then I have two other
dudes a three actually but two dudes who
are crushing it uh
um and then I I have that one guy in the
testimonial on my Instagram page and the
other guy I'm going to be putting him up
soon uh he doesn't know yet but I'm
going to surprise him on his 365th day
of sobriety I'm gonna put something up
there for him because he's he's killing
it and uh
neither one of them I don't necessarily
know if they either one of them want to
be competitive but they're utilizing uh
bodybuilding lifestyle if you will the
lifting and the the eating and stuff so
like just listen all of this language
that you're using
killing it bodybuilding lifestyle it's
great like that's that's not Tanya Tanya
doesn't want the bodybuilding lifestyle
she wants you to be Charming dude and
soften up a little bit and you know
smile more and be kinder right but it's
like it that that may be the evolution
of Chris to like serve America right but
like I want to get you paid
sure sure and the people who will love
you the most right now are the ones who
want to kill it who want a bodybuilding
lifestyle without necessarily going to
be a bodybuilder sure and that's what
I'm coming to you for I want you to help
me kill it and get my bodybuilding so
all of that language that's what should
be on the website okay that's what I
should feel and that gets you clients
okay and that gives you like you you
start hitting the six figure business
then you can expand and do whatever you
want because you're you're paying your
bills and growing and expanding and it
doesn't mean bodybuilding lifestyle
forever unless that is the thing that
you want to build your brand around but
that's the easiest path for you to start
making money right now for where you're
right
correct so I have a quick question about
uh YouTube so the shorts is that like
sort of like the way we do reels on
Instagram and Facebook and and Tick Tock
is it the same idea same concept I mean
shorts was was taken from Instagram
reels which was taken from tick tock
so they're all similar
um the the
thing with shorts on YouTube is
a lot of times that it could potentially
take away from the views on your video
on your long form videos a lot of times
the people who watch a short video they
don't want to watch longer foam content
so then it doesn't lead to sub
subscribers who watch your content who
then will hire you and buy your stuff so
it could be a fast way to grow the
Channel with views and Subs but it's
usually the wrong people who don't
convert to any things that you want to
sell so you know what's your goal if
your goal is I just want to hit 100 000
subscribers as soon as possible
shorts could be the fastest way to do it
apart from advertising which would be
you know the fastest way I guess but
you're spending a lot of money doing it
uh
but they won't convert to people hiring
you or buying in your stuff or you know
going into your funnels Etc uh the way I
would look at shorts now is
ultimately the goal I would think for
everybody if you really want to have an
impact is thinking daily content on your
YouTube channel
whatever your long form content is right
now like how many videos are you making
in a week Maria
well I've I've runed into like three now
I know there's a good spot who's again
most people are in that three at all
right so if you're at three then I would
look at on the on the off days on the
four put a short okay
but the ultimate goal would be to
ideally go daily long form
so that's ten plus right 10 minutes plus
10 minute Plus for videos yeah could I
use like my reels to do the shorts like
because I have all these reels from my
other
you know ideally you take so here's
here's our process I don't think you're
even talking about this movement maker
so here's some like bonus stuff for for
you guys here who show up to the
Insiders here's what we'll do uh
ideally uh if you have it as 45 seconds
then it can also go to Twitter maybe
maybe you care about Twitter maybe you
don't care about Twitter yeah it doesn't
matter but 60 seconds is for all the
other ones Instagram reels YouTube
shorts Tech talk
Tick Tock is the most forgiving Place
meaning if you post something there
it's much more about the content than
than the Creator so on Instagram or
YouTube a lot of it is this is a Maria
video like oh cool what's her next video
I want to watch it so you're getting
people to watch it based off of who's
already watched your videos uh and the
downside is if you post a a bad video
the next video you post people are less
likely to see it
on Instagram and on YouTube
so there's a there's a consequence of
posting you know air codes bad content
the likelihood of your next video doing
as well will be lower Tick Tock is
completely different where it's almost
zero about who's actually following you
and much more about the topic which is a
lot more forgiving so you could post I
don't know how many times we post a tick
tock a day like three to five times a
day we're posting a tech talk
and and it's okay if the video doesn't
pop or blow up because most of the
people watching the video aren't people
who who are following me or care about
me
it's based off the the interest the
category the topic so you could post a
lot more to tick tock so what we'll do
is we'll post the most to tick tock
whatever performs the best we then pull
to our Instagram and pull to our YouTube
shorts so if you had a lot of content a
lot of options say you were posting
every day or two times a day to tick
tock cool whatever performs the best you
then take to your Instagram
as a reel one time a day or it's two
times a day to tick tock take the best
one once a day on Instagram and then the
best ones are those you take to your
YouTube which would be three times a
week because you're making four times a
week long form videos or the opposite
right so
um if you have a lot of content that's
that's how we kind of reverse Engineers
so Tick Tock we just throw a whole bunch
of stuff at tick tock because it doesn't
punish you if you don't do well okay and
then that allows us to be on the other
platforms too
that's great cool we might we might dive
in like detailed on movement makers or
like with graphs and everything and
examples that people want that but
that's just a little a little taste
the first question that came in on the
poll was how can we focus on one thing
with too much information
so at the beginning of anything
it always can feel overwhelming right if
you're thinking about I want to start on
YouTube I want to start on social media
I want to start writing my book I want
to start like whatever new project you
want to start it always feels
overwhelming it always feels like it's
too big it always feels like you don't
have enough information you can't wrap
your head around what's going on and so
what I like to do is just trying to
figure out where are the boundaries like
what is it that I actually need to learn
and at the beginning I get super
frustrated of any project
just trying to figure out where are the
gates because I'm I love optimizing I
love efficiency I love making things as
tight as possible but at the beginning
creativity is messy and you can't
prematurely optimize something we try to
optimize too soon when you don't know
the boundaries you end up not being able
to make any progress so at the beginning
of any project I will take some time sit
in my frustration and just basically try
to figure out where the gates are around
it so what's the most recent one I think
um figuring out AdWords and advertising
has been one of those things for me in
figuring out okay what ads do I run how
do I put them up what are the placements
what what's the conversions uh the
demographics you know all of the things
that
seem overwhelming at the beginning and
it's frustrating to know which ads to
serve to which audiences and just tests
and test and test and testing until I
kind of get a sense of okay this is
where the gates are and then
make it efficient and squish it down and
optimize it
um so at the beginning for me it's just
research right research plane testing
find don't get so overwhelmed by the the
big picture that you don't take any
action right like what's the smallest
possible thing you can just do to start
gaining momentum and then
that first step seems impossible but
when you go back it's like oh I did that
I did that first step that's pretty cool
now it's Evan Evan's holding up to two
percent I got mine I got mine too make
the two percent happen anyway so I hope
that makes sense right it's taking that
big idea that seems overwhelming that
seems impossible and then finding one
step that you can do today because as
long as you have it as some big dream in
your head that is impossible then you
never take any action and then you know
it's a year later and you still haven't
done the thing yet because it still
seems too impossible and I see it all
the time with entrepreneurs who are
getting started people ask you how do I
get started on YouTube how do I get
started as an author how do I get
started as a speaker and and you think
you've got to have this perfect plan and
the perfect gear and all of this perfect
stuff and then it's a year later and you
still haven't done the thing immediate
action momentum I see Zayn's big smiling
um Dan joined me on my uh three days a
week now I stream League of Legends and
answer business questions and Zen joined
in and they said yeah I'm gonna start
making YouTube videos uh and I think it
was original timeline was like next
month or in two months or something it's
like dude Zan come on tonight make a
video let's go get get your video up uh
and then he did and he got his first
video up and then the second video and
then another video like he's got his
phone out he's gonna make another video
right now
like that's the process and and it's not
gonna be perfect being off your phone
and it's and it's not gonna be the the
lighting that you want or the gear that
you want or the background that you want
and your thoughts may not come out as
clearly as you want that's the beginning
like the beginning is supposed to be
messy so don't stress out about having
all the information at the beginning
just go just create like in that
momentum uh you will start getting some
results
um and additional momentum to keep on
building right and
I think a lot of you know my story about
losing that 40 million deal when I was
22 years old of just trying to be too
perfect and have it all planned out and
you know
going to Market and then seeing Oh My
Perfect plan was not what people wanted
anyway right like your perfect version
of a YouTube video is not going to be
perfect anyway once you start creating
it's going to change it's going to take
a million different turns
um so the best way to do it is to do it
so to take action against that big idea
so it doesn't just stay
uh doesn't just State an idea for you
forever okay next question Nicolette
said what is your advice on where to
start with content creation if you
haven't started at all
so the easiest place to start is
actually Instagram stories like easy is
easiest easiest way to start is
Instagram stories it's on Instagram
they're 15 seconds Max it's it's meant
to be informal it's meant to be
non-edited it's meant to be kind of
behind the scenes and so if you're
trying to develop that practice of being
a speaker of creating content I
recommend starting like Ground Zero you
start with Instagram stories and try to
find three to ten moments during the day
that you can share you know you where's
my book built the serve right you guys
you guys you have this book if you're in
this group right you've got it hopefully
you've read it it's not just some fancy
ornament sitting there on your desk
Zan's got two copies Victor's got his
copy
I love it Evans I know has got an entire
Shelf full of uh of books somewhere
there at the top
um
so you know it's it's about starting to
share the way that you think to serve
other people you you're weird you're
different you're I like to say you're a
weird duck you think differently your
job is to teach me to think like you
think so some of the things that may
seem super obvious to you for other
people is not so obvious right if I look
at even your your rooms for those of you
who I can see you know your your rooms
like why does Zan have Captain America
shield on his wall you know why does
Evan have Napoleon Hill on his wall and
Andrew Carnegie Doug's Doug's trying to
hold up built to serve but it's being
blocked out by that by the Florida coast
uh you know why does Jeff have Steve
Jobs up on his wall right Michael's
showing believe up on his wall right
like why why do you have these in your
rooms in your offices it means something
to you and that may be like maybe maybe
Zan's been a Captain America fan since
he was eight years old I don't know like
maybe that's just so natural normal for
him but for other people it's kind of
weird to have a Captain America shield
on your door right like most people
don't have that so explain why it's
there right explain why you pick up this
book most people would know that that's
Napoleon Hill up on Evan's wall right so
explain why he's there explain what that
message means and finding these micro
moments throughout the day from your
your routines your habits what you're
eating for lunch what happened when a
client emailed you like the way you
respond to things is different and so
that's your job it's not about how fancy
the the video footage is it's your job
to teach me to think the way that you
think and sometimes this is hard to step
out of because for you it's so natural
and normal because you've been doing it
for a long time but for somebody else
who's watching you from the outside it's
it's weird and different and that's the
whole point and so Instagram stories I
think is the easiest way to start just
to get you into that practice of
creating content
again you know three to ten different
stories a day it takes 15 seconds Max so
you know at the minimum I'm asking for
45 seconds a day right this is not a
groundbreaking amount of time to create
content right 45 seconds three 15 second
stories a day
when you're ready to jump in and make it
much bigger
um I would look at YouTube as my primary
home and then I would split up the
content to go to the different platforms
so when you can get to making one
YouTube video per week I want a 10
minute YouTube video every week and it
could just be taking me deeper right
Zayn has a 10 minute story about the
Captain America shield Evan has a 10
minute story about what he's learned
from Napoleon Hill Jeff has a 10-minute
story about what that Bullseye thing is
behind him right you know Michael has a
10-minute story about what believe means
to him right it's a it's just taking me
deeper into it but the the Instagram
content stories is the first way to just
start practicing getting it
out of your head out of your mouth and
into the internet right into the world
um once you can get to 10 minute video a
week that's where I want you to be on
YouTube
because those that content will live
forever and then you split up the
content to go to all the different
social media platforms so until you're
ready to do that Instagram stories once
you're ready to do that then you can
still do the Instagram stories right
it's just add-on it's additive again the
Instagram stories are 45 seconds a day
everybody here has 45 seconds today to
record three Instagram stories to tell
me about something that's happening
um in your life and and it's not this
was really hard for me at the beginning
of making content was it's not about
uh
telling me what you ate for lunch and
just kind of vlogging
it's trying to find a message in
everything so if you're showing me your
lunch tell me why you picked that thing
like why are you picking asparagus for
lunch or why are you having that Donut
for lunch like why why are you picking
that thing like explain to me the
thought process behind it right I'm
having the donut because I'm celebrating
my 50th birthday or something right like
I'm getting the asparagus because I have
you know I want to live a keto lifestyle
or whatever it is right like explain the
thought process behind the decisions I
remember when I first got started on
social Twitter was was blowing up and I
thought Twitter was stupid like this
looks so stupid people are just sharing
pictures of their lunch and cats and I
have no interest in just sharing I'm I'm
a pretty uh private person believe it or
not like I have no need for you to know
what's happening in my life I have no
need to share it
but when I realized oh this is actually
thought leadership content that the
reason behind making this book or the
reason behind having these pictures on
my wall it's not about me showing off
it's about me trying to help other
people think the way I think so that
they can improve their lives as well so
everything you've got around you is a
story that hopefully has helped you
improve your life some way now bring
that back to bring not bring that back
into the audience so that they can learn
from you like why are you here why did
you pick up build to serve what was the
biggest lesson that you got from it all
of these could be individual stories
that again teaches people to think like
you think so Stephen wrote why is it
important to tell your story Okay so
and built the serve we talked about this
right
people need to connect to you
if they don't feel like you know what
they've gone through they won't listen
to you so
you know Evan has shared a lot about his
story with uh alcohol addiction and
you know you would look at Evan like
right now and you would say oh this guy
looks like he's polished and clean and
knows what he's doing and has his life
in order and you wouldn't necessarily
think that he was addicted to alcohol
and and I know Evan's okay with me kind
of sharing bits of his story here on the
Stream
so if somebody came and was struggling
with alcohol addiction and they came
across Evan and he said hey here's what
you have to do these three things
they say yeah that's great man but you
don't know what I've been through
you don't know what it's like you don't
you don't I mean I'm addicted you look
at you you've got your life together
it's all sorted out meanwhile Evan knows
exactly what it's like uh to contemplate
suicide to to be you know massively
addicted to have a lot of self-hatred
because of of the addiction of that
cause
and so unless people know what you've
been through they won't listen to your
advice like Evan has some of the best
advice to help people overcome it but
unless they know his story about how he
came through that they won't listen to
him
because people will naturally think well
you don't know what I'm going through
and so this is where you have to share
your story where you came from even the
journey that you're still on right we're
still growing we're still learning we're
never done learning growing getting
better and improving but where did you
struggle where did you come from because
ultimately your purpose like we talked
about in built to serve is to help other
people who currently are who you used to
be
right there are many people who are Evan
from eight years ago
I've been 10 Smith we got two evidence
in the group I like using that as an
example right but there's also many
people who are having Carmichael from
eight years ago and that's who you're
talking to and that's who you'll love
helping the most you know Evan tinsman
will love helping anybody right and he's
been uh an amazing human in in the
movement makers group in this group even
when we first did our session in
Pittsburgh uh he was bringing value to
all the other people in the room he just
wants to help right he wants to
contribute which is fantastic
but helping somebody who
is currently struggling through alcohol
addiction is currently struggling with
self-worth is currently struggling with
uh potential you know suicide he'll love
helping those people more than holding
the door for somebody at a grocery store
or buying a Starbucks the person behind
him in line because that's who he used
to be and it's the same thing for all of
you and I'm telling Evan story because I
know it better I don't know all of your
stories you know in detail but you've
all been through something
and those are the people who you're
going to love helping out the most it
just feels so much better it feels so
fulfilling that you represent hope to
them that when they see you
and what you've come through
it represents possibility for them
because they don't see possibility for a
lot of you where you are right now is
impossible
for where Evan is right now it's
impossible he shouldn't be here he
shouldn't be doing the stuff that he's
doing right now it's impossible Evan
from X number of years ago would look at
this guy and say there's no way you're
going to be doing that that's not
possible
but he did it yeah and so have you and
all of you are here right now and the
version of you five ten years ago would
say that's not possible and so that's
your job is to show other people who
currently are you from five or ten years
ago that it's possible that there is
hope that you can grow that you can
overcome that you can climb out of this
hole that you're in
but without sharing your story to the
question that Stephen asked without
sharing your story uh nobody's gonna
listen to you so you've got all this
great information you've got the
knowledge the tools the the desire to
help the willingness all of it and you
can help and you know that it can help
but nobody's going to listen to you
because they feel like you don't know
what you're talking about because you
haven't been through what I've been
through right
so that's why it's super important to
share your story and and
um it's scary
it's scary to share your story it's
scary to put it out there it's scary for
people to know
um what you've been through you know
like using Evan against an example he's
has a super successful uh practice uh in
insurance and it could be scary to let
that out to have clients have customers
have Partners have people in the
community know that you almost killed
yourself and you were addicted to
alcohol right like now you're not normal
anymore now you don't fit in maybe as
much anymore it could be scary for
people to know what you've been through
um
but if you are silent it perpetuates a
silence it means everybody else who's
struggling with it they stay silent too
and they become afraid to share and your
willingness to share to be brave to be
courageous to put your story out there
inspires other people to say hey I'm not
alone I'm not the only one going through
this and it's okay to share my story too
so I see that as your all of you your
responsibility to be able to do that so
okay Esmeralda is here how do I overcome
the fear of being in front of the camera
or sharing pictures of myself well
where's Esmeralda Esmeralda we could do
it right now it's called turning on your
camera
hey we got lots of people hey there she
is Esmeralda
[Laughter]
it's one set look at all the high fives
and fist bumps and flexes you're getting
right I mean that's that's the start
uh so I do a couple of things one
is I tell myself that being afraid is
not a good enough reason
you don't want to teach yourself that
I'm afraid and I don't do it I'm afraid
and I play small I'm afraid to chase
down my dream and then I don't go for it
because that becomes this negative cycle
that we repeat and I love that you're
like in a in a grocery store or
convenience store somewhere there well
they're all still tuning in to the live
it's amazing uh but being afraid is not
a good enough reason if you can catch it
like the reason I want to do this but
I'm but I'm afraid that just mental
break down that wall being afraid is no
longer a good enough reason because
everything that you want out of life is
on the other side of what you're afraid
of
every growth every opportunity every
breakthrough every client like
everything you want to do comes from
doing things that you're afraid of
otherwise if you're never afraid then
what then you
you stay stuck doing what you're doing
you just stay inside your comfort zone
it's just your life photocopying every
single day
are you at your job that's amazing I
think she's working there it's awesome
Esmeralda joining in
I remember when I had my one of the only
jobs I had was doing data entry at this
company and they wouldn't let me listen
to music so it was back when we had a CD
what's a CD man it's like the Walkman
but for CDs like a portable little CD
player so I used to have that on the
floor and then I ran a wire through my
jeans and I always wore a turtleneck and
I ran I got an extra long extension cord
for my headset for my headphones and I'd
run the wire under my turtleneck and
just pop out here to get one little
sound Bud to go into my ears so I can
listen to some uh mostly Andrea Bocelli
at the time while I was doing this super
boring data entry work so I love it I
love I love the hacks
um okay so to that question one is
fear alone is not a good enough reason
the second part is you're trying to
serve you're trying to serve you want to
help you're doing this you know you're
afraid to get in front of the camera but
why do you want to get in front of the
camera
take it from I want to it's not about
you being seen it's not about you being
this big famous name it's about you have
a message that can help people you're
here trying to serve and whenever I flip
it to it's about the audience it's about
the people who will see this is that
even if only five people see this video
maybe two out of those five people this
could actually be something
life-changing for them
it's not about you it's about them
that always gives me that extra little
bit of of confidence and push to go off
and do the thing that that I'm afraid to
do so I balance it between those two
things right I'll tell myself I'm Evan
christili Carmichael I do difficult
things or I do scary things or I do the
things I'm afraid of Plus
I'm here to serve and I'm here to help
and my message
can hopefully Touch Somebody Today it
may not but it's your intention going in
like the intention behind the action of
being in front of the camera is not to
screw people over it's not just to make
yourself famous it's to try to help us
to try to serve
and so I always take that mindset going
in before uh whenever I'm super nervous
uh or before never making any piece of
content it helps when you're when you're
even filming your own YouTube videos
because sometimes it's hard when you're
at home in an office maybe with Corona
you haven't seen any humans for the last
little bit and interact with them and
you just even here I'm talking just into
a camera and it's awesome to be able to
see your faces up here on the screen
to remind yourself that hey this is a
video that's not just me in my office by
myself you're making this video to try
to touch somebody else's life and when
you take that as an intention your video
will be better
when you just focused on oh am I looking
at the camera and is my mic set up and
all this other stuff your video won't be
as good compared to if you actually
picture somebody
in your head I used to do this all the
time because I had a hard time getting
to the zone and I was making content I
would picture somebody and I'm I'm
making this video for him this video is
just for him and I'm speaking to him and
and that would Channel him as I pressed
record on my camera and I'd always end
up getting a much better video man time
flies it's crazy we already got time
let's get to let's get to like super
rapid fire
uh uh how to deliver the idea message in
a simple way
uh oh hot chocolate readings I would I
would do a 30 second hot chocolate
reading every day and post it to
Instagram
hot chocolate reading of the day and
then whatever whatever the whatever
comes at every day right every day for
30 seconds
um from Denise what type of videos go
viral in your opinion if you know if I
had a recipe for making a viral video
every time
that'd be amazing like that's what
everybody's going after but really be
looking at
make the video that you from five years
ago badly needs right make the video
that the you from five or ten years ago
badly means because the youth from five
or ten years ago probably wouldn't watch
an Evan Carmichael video
like ah that guy he's too energetic he's
too positive that can't be real I don't
know
you know like you don't want to listen
to those guys
but
you could you could touch you from five
or ten years ago in a way that Evan
Carmichael or Tony Robbins or Brendan
Bouchard or whoever else can't
and that's I think even much more
important than worrying about a viral
video that that blows up on the Internet
is having an impactful video that
changes somebody's life
so I'm still trying to make the content
that
uh that I need right now but also that
like five years ago Evan still needs uh
so that's always kind of in the back of
my head as well
I haven't since been saying disagree ooh
okay your content helped get this Evan
to where he is now well I love it thank
you everyone appreciate the love man
um loved that five to ten years ago idea
brilliant yeah just to imagine you
from five or ten years ago or somebody
who is like you and you're making
content for that person because you know
again Jeff from five or ten years ago is
thinking a different way he's not
doesn't have as much of a growth mindset
is
not wanting to listen to a lot of the
messages that are being put up there you
know he would look at what you're doing
now so that's crazy you know with books
on the shelf and Bullseye and all these
goals and accomplish like you wouldn't
think that that would be possible uh and
so you can reach Jeff from five or ten
years ago in a way that nobody else can
if you want to get a copy of Bill to
serve and join us live for our next
training with me to ask your questions
you can go get the book right there next
to me right there I'll see you there
I'll see you to get the book it's a good
one much love